hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar advanced essays for high
throughput assessments of ion channel
inhibition and cardiac toxicity I am
Judy Aurora collaborates and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth the leading scientific social
networking website and provider or
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by molecular devices
molecular devices is one of the world's
leading providers of instrument software
and reagents for life science research
pharmaceutical and biocera puted
development with over 130 thousand
placements and laboratories around the
world the company's instruments of
catalyzed brilliant scientific research
described in over 25,000 peer-reviewed
publications included within a broad
product portfolio are platforms for high
throughput screening genomic and
cellular analysis colony selection and
microplate detection these leading edge
products empower scientists to improve
productivity and effectiveness
ultimately accelerating research and the
discovery of new sherek eunuchs to learn
more visit www.hp.com/recycle credits
please click on the see e button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits you can
post questions to the speakers during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them into
the Q&A box which will open when you
click the green to renee button at the
lower left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
lower left I now presented a speakers
and zel PhD and Oksana Steranko PhD
from molecular devices dr. Zhao is a
field application scientist supporting
reagents flex station 3 flipper and
automated electrophysiology platform she
received a PhD in biology at
Pennsylvania State University and
completed postdoctoral training in the
Department of neuroscience at Johns
Hopkins University School of Medicine
dr. Zhao has 18 years of experience in
molecular biology and genetics 8 years
of experience in ion channel biology 4
years of experience in cellular imaging
and 8 years of experience and assay
development and high throughput screen
the latter includes 5 years of
experience as a project leader at the
Johns Hopkins ion channel Center dr.
Zhao has authored and co-authored in 20
peer-reviewed papers and prestigious
journals including PNAS Cell Journal of
Neuroscience molecular pharmacology and
ask a drug development technologies dr.
Surran Co is a research scientist
working on development of new
technologies for imaging and high
content analysis she also has previous
experience working on drug discovery and
drug development at several biotech
companies in the San Francisco Bay Area
the focus of dr. Steranko current
scientific research is on both methods
for high-throughput in-vitro toxicity
screening including 3d models she has a
PhD in biochemistry and BS in biology
dr. Zull will now begin her presentation
good morning today I am going to talk
with you about predictive assessment of
colleagues safety eating through
protective press hi cervical screening
assays for individual potency evaluation
of cottage line channel inhibitors
high-tech safety is of paramount
importance in contemporary drug
development as you can see from this
slide 95 compounds always draw from the
US market due to their unwanted side
effect cardiovascular safety is one of
the dating regions for the
discontinuation of the
drugs from 1990 to 2010 15 market drugs
will withdraw due to arrhythmia
these drugs are listed in this table as
you can see 14 of them or withdraw up to
1997 these drugs include compounds
seeking to rectify card arrives to a
problem for example entire is near agent
Hank 9 but also includes compounds with
totally different indications for
example antihistamine society and
Estanza these compounds cause TT
promulgation and increased risk of casa
de pomme sometimes even cause sudden
death electrical activity of heart is
measured by ECG or electrocardiogram by
placing electrodes on specific points on
theme to measure the activity in ECG the
interval between key wave and P wave is
called QT interval QT interval
corresponds to ventricular
depolarization and reposition this
figure in shows recording or cardio my
sense this is a cell and this is a
grass-type at one beat cost up to one
action potential ventricular action
potential duration corresponds QT
interval there are five phases in
ventricular action potential a variety
of channels play important roles in
generational ventricular action
potential for example potassium channels
they play important roles in phase 3 for
reproduction
if realization is slowed the durational
vengeful action potential is prompt
Chris Donnelly KT info is prompt
sometimes from Gatien will cause toxic
on her channel is included by human into
Google G it is voltage-gated potassium
channel expressing
my life it plays a very important role
in reproduction as shown in this slide
rule prevents normal her occurrence if
the channel activity is blocked by
compounds its current will be greatly
reduced as shown in red as a result
retardation is slowed and durational
eventually action potential is planned
it caused long QT syndrome hurt has a
very unique feature this shows for
misgives interactions with compounds of
various chemical structures in fact
among these drugs withdraw due to their
unwanted side-effects many of them
inhibitor hug given the importance of
correct safety FDA has provided
guidelines for cardiac vascular risk
assessments of new chemical entity one
day is IC H at 7 B which is non clinical
evaluation of the potential for delayed
ventricular repolarization QT interval
foundation by human pharmaceuticals and
the other one is IC h e 14 which is a
clinical evaluation of kt and cracker QT
into elongation and pro a rhythmic
potential for no antiarrhythmics drops
since the most common magnatum of
teaching elongation by sound vehicles
the inhibition of heard that is the
sense of right heah it is required in IC
h at 17 to attach component act on Kirk
this figure shows the general non
clinical testing strategy for assessing
risk for delay the ventricular
revelation and QT into elongation in
this strategy compound exam will be
evaluated from ITR or hers results from
these asses who will be used together
with other information
to provide integrated risk assessment of
compounds several essays have been
developed to evaluate compound adverse
effects on her or cardiomyocyte these
Isis include fluorescence base silent
infrastructure using flipper and
automated electrophysiology assay of
heard both Isis are performed using cell
lines they were expressing her channel
completely automated electrophysiology
is a throughput is higher and the cost
of data point is lower in flippers that
and infrequently in a foreign field like
I'm going to show you the data from
flipper sound in processing in
comparison between the results from the
first item in frog sensei and automated
electrophysiology actually I would like
to mention that super tight repress
system can be used to measure housing
the dynamics in Korea my site
differentiated from IPM see my colleague
Oksana will show the data from
criticality methane of Korea my sites
incur plantation before showing you the
data I would like to provide you an
overview of the potential plus system
protection system usually on the lab is
the latest generation of flipper system
it is a bottom read for resonance
imaging play reader which in created
liquid handling you can read and
dispense simultaneously which is
required for fast kinetic acid such as
calcium acid and done an influx of a
paper can be applied to 96 384 or 1536
well formats it utilized LEDs of
excitation resource and use EMC CD or
intensified CCD camera to detect signal
optics is visit changeable now it is in
futures of various wavelengths
available for access using different
diets of fluorescent proteins there are
five states of flipper four of them
for plates which allows multi addition
assays the system is operated via spring
work software wheel works in industry we
know software flicker protocols are set
up very dragon job of pre-configured
modules seen works
provides on the flight data analysis if
users want to try different software for
data analysis data can be exported in
worksheet compatible formats to be used
in other software this slide show traces
from the present in success rate of CRO
channels using a stable cell line the
abstract it is time the y-axis is
response over baseline increases from
these walls will curb channels or
actually to open black traces from these
walls where the activity of her channels
is completely blocked one shape is from
one wall in this experiment as a plate
was detected on flipper for 10 seconds
to establish fluorescence station then
symbols buffer containing both Salomon's
and attacking lines was applied to all
the world present signals were detected
for another 120 seconds as you can see
in this slide
fluorescence signal increased
dramatically involved where her channels
are actually to open however in these
walls where the activity of heard is
completely blocked the increase of
fluorescence signal is much much smaller
the difference between the two
populations
reflects activity of heard channels
which is about two-fold increase in
fluorescence signal data is shown in a
previous slide was obtained using the
new flipper present kit this kit
utilizes a novel Stalin Sensodyne in a
special marking knife the sad incentive
that is
loaded into cells once platon pine
channels are activated pheromones flux
into cells and bind to cell incentives
die as a result present signals increase
if as a allows functional measurement of
calcium channel activity and like seven
sensitize martin diet in the after
cellular solution and can significantly
reduce the background the axon is
homogeneous and no more chassé in such a
say well well variations are going to
reduce by eliminating washing staff and
these prime factors are increased super
potassium kit is very easy to use
component a B and C and mix together to
make dye loading solution anti loading
solution to microplace and incubate it
for one hour and 37 degree then the
plates are ready to actually on separate
hydro plug three channels are
voltage-gated potassium channels they
can be operated to open by membrane be
predation in average we increase after
cellular passing ion concentration to
depolarize membrane to activate her
channels to obtain optimal results as
the observation is required in Hertz
elementary we tested various
concentrations of sodium and potassium
ions to identify an optimal condition
her channels were operated by 10
millimolar or 20 min motor after
cellular protected lines present signals
were measured when the after cellular
standing iron concentration was at 0.5
minimal one mini molar or 2 min water
blue lines are from the examine where
channels are activated by 20 minimal
replacing lines in after cell resolution
like green lines are from experiments
where channels were activated by 10
millimolar potassium ions in actress and
resolution all your lines are controlled
where CRO channels are not operated we
found the fluorescence signal we know is
the largest with stimulus buffer of 1
millimolar Salim and 10 minimal
potassium then we tested company found
using this condition Salim si has
included they developed using brand F
kit brand acid requires ocean to assess
as a performance which have been known
heard inhibitors a stamina timid eyes
and to sanity using 3 present kit and
bring up kids
we compared as a window seat prime
factor and come home from country from
both kids century or from experiments
using preferred testing kit d3 or from
experiments using brand asked it as you
can see present signals of this groups
increased the proximate two-fold
presence signals of this groups
increased approximate point fivefold
prefer present it allows larger signal
window three prime factors of flipper
kazantip is 485 the prime factor of
brand of Clips is 0.6 t4 I see CDs of
testing compounds are very similar
between z2 acted according to their own
favorite present it can be used to
assess compounds on curb the better to
use free potassium tips in cruise larger
signal window in the batter and big
trans actor electric authority is go
standard to measure internal activity to
further assess whether free press
ultimately can be used to predict
compound adverse effects our Kirk we
tested seven non curve inhibitors and
compared the ICC's
with values from automatic eruption
physiology as a using ironworks
barracuda concentration-dependent curves
from these two assays for project in the
top left and top right panel
respectively I see cities are summarized
in the table below ratios will take them
between IP 50s from super ugly and I
appreciate this from our works by
recruiter asset as you can see all
ratios are lesson 3 suggesting that
compound potency is similar in addition
the compound rank order retains
therefore flipper Asylum a drain can be
used to predict compound effect on her
given the low cost and higher throughput
Philip rastelli methane can be used in
early drug development stage to assess
compound effect although the most common
mechanism of teaching to elongation by
drugs is inhibition of heard from geisha
of the action potential can result from
decrease in the activation of the inward
sodium or calcium currents nav 1.5 is
devoted gated sodium channels expressing
cardiomyocytes in phase zero the
upstroke of the action potential is
primarily a consequence of a rapid
transient influx of sodium currents
through nerve 1.5 channels cv 1 point 2
is outside voltage-gated calcium
channels express in cardiomyocytes in
phase 2 the plateau of the action
potential is a refraction of a balance
between the influx of calcium current
through C V 1.2 and outward repolarizing
potassium currents fertilizers have been
developed to assess
compound effect on lap 1.5 and cAVU 1.2
channels first asses of nav 1.5 and cv
1.2 channels
they're using member potential dye and
slippery calcium advocate respectively
as you might know membrane potential dye
kit is a primary advocate for monitoring
ion channel activity it measures member
activity regardless of ion types it is a
homogeneous as a three prime factors are
increased by eliminating washing errors
molecular devices also offer several
flipper calcium acid kids including
early talks career consisted formulated
for applications in Cairo my sites these
calcium advocates are established
regions for calcium mobilization
screenings they provide larger signal we
know in our lab toxic in the following
slides I'm going to show you the results
from clip remember to ensure that action
of nav 1.5 channels
this slide shows data from cho cells
expressing potassium channels elevated
after cellular calcium ion
concentrations were used to deep-fry the
membrane membrane potential was measured
using both member potential dye and
Lanyon pashtun comparison with beta with
patch clamping results showed good
coloration it's demonstrated that
membrane potential dye
can measure memory activity member
tantra dye has fast response time this
slide shows an overlay of data from many
patch clamp and flipper a member
tanjadave
16 millimolar potassium chloride was
used to deep-fry the membrane orange
triangle represents data from trip
remember potential die as a and a green
diamond represents data from menu
patch-clamp
as you can see member plan show as a
beta and patch clamping results show
good coloration
the ratcheting is known sodium channel
opener in membrane potential
fluorescence assay of nav 1.5 the
ratcheting is used to hold a sodium
channel in its open state granted in
front of sodium I into cell depolarize
the membrane leading to an increase in
fluorescence there are two flip
remembers potential asset kids blue and
red and shown in the slide comparison of
the cellular response to veracity using
a strip remembered potential red and a
blue after kids too similar ec50
concentration using the blue advocate is
slightly right shifted at the thirty
seven point two micro molar compared to
twenty point four micro molar with the
rad advocate cash reduction is a potent
sodium channel blocker its effect on
that one point five was evaluated using
both red and blue advocates results
showed that ic50 was point seventy nine
Michael Mullen with red advocate and it
was to micromolar with blue advocate
goals are similar to publish
conventional patch-clamp data to point
for micro molar change in fluorescence
was greater with red advocate in
addition this factor of red advocate was
higher than that of true advocate to
obtain optimal results we recommend
comparing these two tears in your eyes
Ray said O'Kane is the local energetic
that works by rocking sodium channels in
a user dependent manner
results of the flip remember potential
advocate showed that ic50 was nine point
55 micro motor with an advocate in the
words
51.3 micro molar with blue acid kick
both are more potent than the results
from an action physiology data this
factor is higher with that acid kick
higher potency measurements
in this assay to be expected as
ratcheting blocks the channel in the
open stage maximizing the exposure of
the channel to the doping and thus
increasing its apparent potency next I'm
going to show you some data from flipper
assay of CA v 1.2 channels in the
stripper calcium channel as a elevated
oppressive iron concentrations were used
to evoke the response to find optimal
conditions this phone was revoked by
Pelham chloride at various concentration
representative traces in response to
various present concentrations are shown
in the last tunnel signal window risk
after cellular potassium concentration
was prodded in the right panel we found
quite a mega molar calcium chloride
resulted in larger signal window then we
tested no inhibitors using this
condition to known l-type calcium
channel inhibitors the fighting in Iraq
Mill were tested concentration response
curves were plotted IG city of Nevada
team with 42 nano molar and I see 50 of
revenue was 10 points for my motor both
are in good agreement with results from
electrophysiology acid suggesting that
this free passage can be used to predict
compound effect on CA V 1 point 2
channels in summary surveys
fluorescence functional assays have been
developed using a separate catcher plus
instrument for individual potency
evaluation of inhibitors of herb nat 1.5
and CB 1.23 i'm channels playing
important roles in generating and
maintaining normal cardiac electrical
activity compared to results from
electrophysiological recording
techniques compound potency of
non-korean jurors
tetrodotoxin noon on calcium channel
inhibitors from flipper assays is
comparable in addition compounds rank
order retains given its low cost and
high throughput in flipper assays can be
used through individual compound
assessment at early drug development
stage thank you very much for your
attention
thank you dr. self for that informative
presentation we will now hear from dr.
sprinkle I will hand the presentation
over to her
thank you for your introduction in a
second part of our webinar I will
describe phenotypic assays this is
induced pluripotent stem cell derived
cardiomyocytes for evaluating the
effects of compounds on cardiac
physiology kirk a toxicity remains one
of the main reasons comparable with
hepatotoxicity for drug attrition during
clinical trials current preclinical
approaches for card a physiologic
evaluation of chemicals rely almost
exclusively on animal models and this
approach has significant limitation in
terms of the cost in complexity of the
studies so there is a great pressing
need for the development of
comprehensive multi parametric screening
strategies to provide improved
predictability of cardio toxic effects
novel approaches need to rely on
functional studies instead of
traditional set a toxicity measurements
because interference with normal
cellular electrophysiology can have
impact on organ function as an
alternative to primary cardiomyocytes
and myocardial tissue preparations human
inducible pluripotent stem cell derived
models have recently emerged as
physiologically relevant and highly
reproducible options for cardio toxicity
testing IPS e derived cardiomyocytes
especially attractive as they form
synchronously bit in mono life that can
be used to reproduce drug associated
physiologic phenotypes we used fast
kinetic fluorescence assay that monitors
changes in intracellular calcium fluxes
fluorescent measurements of
intracellular calcium flags were
performed using flippered Petra
high-throughput screening system from
molecular devices the SA can be done in
96 or 384-well formats with automatic
addition of compounds we have tested a
library of cardio toxic compounds that
contains 131 compounds including known
until arrhythmia
anti-cancer anti-inflammatory
near elliptic compounds as well as
cardio safe drugs used as negative
controls compounds represented different
mechanism of action blocking of ion
channels and Reina receptor antagonist
kinase inhibitors and others several
phenotypic descriptors were derived
using screen work big pro software the
readouts included big frequency
expression amplitude decrease as well as
big rise and decay times the NSA allowed
detection of various phenotypic
responses including increasing decrease
of peak amplitude and frequency
prolongation of repolarization step
result in increase of decay time and
degrees which was observed with known
her blockers also peak irregularities
and increase of distance between Peaks
if seen as a result of the effect of
sodium channel blockers evaluation of
changes in billion profiles is important
for detection of functional effects but
high content imaging is an essential
complementary assay for military and
morphological changes and set
electricity effects of compounds contain
AM was used to identify viable
metabolically active cells and to define
morphology features so permeable nuclear
die Hearst was used to measure total
cell count and assess nuclear shape by
the tracker Orange was used for
detection of cells with intact
mitochondria based on testing of library
of cardio toxic compounds we have
estimated the si sensitivity is greater
as 80% with specificity greater than 90%
concentration depending effects of
cleaning compounds on Pixies in billion
rate very visualized using hierarchical
clustering and heat maps analysis allows
clustering of similar classes of
compounds together that may provide
insight for the mechanism of toxic
effects the method allows to address
several
barriers that preclude wide use of human
stem cell derived cells as models for
cardio toxicity screening which include
throughput data integration across
multiple parameters and quantitative
assessment of concentration responses
the effective concentration is 50% of
maximum response ec50 is a reference
point that is used most frequently is
the analysis of in vitro data however
use of 8050 may be problematic in cases
when 50 percent response is far outside
of the range of concentrations tested
positive as using benchmark
concentration or an effective
concentration that causes deviation of
Zarrella from the control for more than
either 1 or 3 standard deviation
overcomes the limitation of a c50
analysis benchmark concentration is used
for toxicity evaluation and can be used
for ranking compounds according to the
toxicity effect in the collaborative
project with the National Institute of
Environmental Health is used to describe
and say to test number of environmental
chemicals for potential cardiotoxicity
effects it is estimated that more than
20% of all cardiovascular diseases
related to environmental exposures in
our world we evaluate the feasibility of
combinatorial screening approach for
analyzing functional and mechanistic
cardiotoxicity we use calcium flux
measurements in combination with high
content imaging level 8 concentration
dependent effects on cardio myocyte
physiology by the country on membrane
potential and cell viability the library
used in this studies is comprised of 69
unique chemicals with mostly limited or
unknown evidence of cardio toxicity the
library included different classes of
compounds pesticides flame retardants
poly aromatic hydrocarbons and some
cardio toxic drugs
shown here are representative sinner
Dybbuk responses which includes
prolongation of the repolarization step
a service changes in amplitude and
frequency cluster analysis of
quantitative concentration response data
for cardio myocyte big frequency and
cell viability displayed here components
that had most of the effect are shown in
additional panel this figure represents
the ranking of 50 to selectively
chemicals selective means the defect of
chemicals have a ratio of effective
concentration for viability to calcium
flag phenotype greater than 3 data
presented for 30 minutes and 24 hours of
exposure most selective compounds shown
on a top
affecting concentration Wailers
presented 469 unique chemicals assessed
for 18 different phenotypes data was
integrated in toxify software for
quantitative bioactivity profiling plots
indicate a relative chemical rampions
per chemical class toxify profiles for
select the representative chemicals
indicated in a second part of my talk I
will describe 3d models for
cardiotoxicity
3d cultures believed to have advantage
of closely a capital agent aspects of
human tissues including architecture
self-organization and cell to cell
interactions in the present study we
develop and characterized kinetic and
confocal imaging methods compatible with
automated instruments and show utility
of 3d cardiac cell cultures for toxicity
screening cardiac steroids spontaneously
contracting and their movement can be
observed in transmitted light rotation
in fluorescence intensity consistent
these mechanical contractions the
observed of treatment of cirrhosis
calcium dive
images were taken by time-lapse
acquisition for cero its taint with
flipper calcium six died and treated
with different compounds so recent
measurements of intracellular calcium
flux were performed using flipper tetra
high-throughput screening system or
imaging system IX MC the workflow for
the screening essay is presented in a
slide human stem cells derived
cardiomyocytes were cultured in ultra
low attachment plates to initiate 3d
spheroid formation u-shaped plates they
used for thorough information
compound addition calcium flux essays
and confocal imaging we developed and
characterized protocol for image
acquisition in pic analysis using the
image Express micro instrument the
recent version of meta Express software
contains an addition of thick analysis
algorithms similar to screen works big
Pro analysis the screen shot presented
here shows the user interface for
analysis setup and calculated readouts
calcium flux si on a flipper d'être
system with steroids performed similarly
to standard foodie culture s a similar
acquisition and analysis protocols were
used but performance of the essay was
dependent on centering steroids in the
well and also size of thyroid phonetic
responses we're in good agreement is
data from 2d cultures tested in parallel
specifically it was observed blockage of
beating this digoxin increase of spacing
between pigs by Lido pain increases
beating rate and amplitude with bicep
retinol as well as decrease of peak
amplitude with propranolol
but also there were several important
differences in the biddin profiles
between 3d steroids and to the cultures
first the didn't rates were
significantly higher for 3d serious
cultures in comparison to 2d cultures
plated at the same sidon density into
conventional 384 cornyn plates second
the absurd amplitude of fluorescent
spikes was significant lower for three
disparate cultures third dividing in
optics and increase of peak decay times
well less profound for 3d spheroid
culture in comparison with to the
culture and finally there were clearly
different concentration and time
responses for number of distance
compounds interestingly in 3d culture it
was a parented concentration
dependencies and ec50 values were
shifted toward greater concentration
suggesting the same dose of compounds
were having less of the effect in 3d
steroids in comparison to 2d cultures
and the ranking number of compounds
notably Herk inhibitors as substantially
less toxic it is possible that
penetration of those compounds into
cardiac cells as well as diffusion
inside thyroids may be limited and
delayed in the case of 3d cultures out
of 15 cardiotoxic compounds tested for
compounds including doxorubicin styrene
as the missile and sunidhi nib caused
significant changes in steroid
morphology and cell viability so it's
lost the spherical shape appears
disintegrated or become flattened it in
addition the number of viable or calcium
positive cells decreased
cytotoxicity effects for the same
compounds were also observed for 2d
cultures
images were taken using automated
confocal microscope with a large field
of view camera the system captured
zeroes in a single image using 10x
objective with either 11 images at 10
micron increments or 17 images at 5
micron increments 3d analysis of the
images was done using the features of
meta Express software which enabled
conversion of stack of 2d images
obtained by the confocal acquisition
into 3d space this appropriate detection
and segmentation of objects 3d analysis
allowed for measuring several parameters
important for phenotypic
characterization of drug-induced
cytotoxicity including thyroid diameter
size volume as well as the numbers and
intensities of life or dead cells ec50
values in micro molars were measured for
tested compounds using peak count as a
readout some compounds had comparable NC
fifties a number of other compounds had
significantly higher if the 50 values
for 3d thyroid cultures more prominent
at earlier time points in summary we
described here advanced method for
imaging and analysis that allow
quantitative characterization of complex
phenotypic effects and seconds 2d and 3d
cardiac cell models from stem cell
derived cells can be successfully used
for the CCT evaluation and compound
screening thank you so much for your
attention I would like to acknowledge
Carol Crittenden made you hammer Shawn
cadence from molecular devices Michael
Hancock Cody Carlson and Blake Hanson
from cellular dynamics
Fabian Grimm and Ivan rusyn for
Texas A&M as well as Kristen Ryan and
Ryman ties from National Institute of
Environmental Health Sciences thank you
Thank You doctors Allen dr. Steranko for
your presentation it's a quick before we
begin the question-and-answer session I
want to advise that series of poll
questions will appear on your screen you
may select your answers and close the
poll questions by clicking on the X in
the right corner a quick reminder for
our audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A buttons at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Zhao and dr. Surran Co will answer
as many questions as time permits and
the first question is the result of the
heard valium at Ray our very good can we
use the cafe to music it for other
targets and what targets have the kid
been applied to yes a case can be you to
other asteroid targets in theory and the
kid can be you to any targets that allow
the science referring to the south we
have AB note of potassium car transfers
as well as voltage gated potassium
channel kv-1 points fiance eating this
cake and these are on our website and
besides this kid can be also used to you
can look for channel openers we do have
a Wagner on our website confirm if
there's a say using the same key to look
for openers of another voltage-gated
potassium channel next one is we have a
herd stable cell line and are interested
in using your tip can use the same
condition that was used in your athlete
while our assay condition can survive
this point for your assay as a good
practice to find the best conditions for
your assay we recommend that you should
optimize assay conditions for your
sidelines and you're asking can you do a
comparison of key count analysis between
flipper and image express micro and if
so does it give the same results
and let me know if you need me to repeat
oh um I can puncture for having a
momentary technical difficulty so hold
on with us for just a moment and I can
repeat that question in just a moment as
dr. Zhao and dr. Surran Co already
answered but we may have just a brief
blip brief technical difficulties okay
are we so let me repeat that question
can we do a comparison of account
analysis between flipper and image
Express micro and if so does it give the
same results yes actually we have done
comparison this from between paper and
XM and actually we get the same count is
the same sample on both instruments even
so that software was slightly different
the only difference was in standard
deviation of the data because since on
image express it's less time for
acquisition and you have less data point
is an experimental error was somewhat
greater okay now where is RF you see why
let me just see how is toxic
how is toxicity determined is it by peak
area or RSU with comparison to the
control and so the parameter which we
use for determining toxicity and also I
see a 50 and effective concentration we
use a number of bits permanent fund or
bits per recording time so it was kind
of frequency of peaks and why it is the
RF you greater in 2d cultures so this is
something which is most likely related
to biology and physiology of cells and
some of the differences
which we see between 2d and 3d so one of
the reasons could visit cells kind of
more strained in 2d and kind of four
because of that the the frequency goes
less and in 3d they kind of contract
more in synchronous but it's kind of
speculation and it definitely reflects
some differences between the system but
why is that it's need to be determined
okay and as we're waiting for more
questions to come in I would like to
once again thank dr. cell and doctors to
rankle for their presentation do you
have any final comments and thank you so
much for the opportunity to present
Snickers yeah and I suppose Canada well
thank you both and there is another
question I just like to post you on what
is the nature of the cell line
it's essentially two parter what is the
nature of the selling are they
continuous primary cell line cultures
because it was said it is derived from
the stem cell yes this is actually stem
cell derived cell types so this is one
of a product of cellular dynamics
international but some other companies
also kind of produce similar products so
those cells are derived from primary
cells usually from blood cells and by
transaction of number of genes which
make self induced pluripotent and then
those cells are differentiated to toward
cardiomyocytes so those cells are
primary you cannot expand them in a
culture but you can grow them for your
experiments and kind of use it and buy
more from a company who produces it in
here I've got another question for you
with a slipper Texas system commune
serve the cytokine effect on cardio
myocyte and channel
activity I would say this would be kind
of interesting question to address but
we haven't done that it wasn't in scope
of our studies so they were focused on
compounds and kind of known model eaters
of cardiac activity q thank you again
dr. Zhao and dr. sprinkle I'd like to
take the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions we
would also like to thank our sponsor
molecular devices for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
C e button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits this webcast can be viewed on
demand through November 9 2017 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who have missed today's live
event until next time goodbye